set a lot of people they think UFOs and
alien visits are the same thing so
what's what's up with that well I think
that most people who are into the UFO
phenomenon and by the way that's not a
small percentage it's one third of the
public one third of the public thinks
there's his gun that's right one two
three together they're ten thousand
twenty thousand sightings reported per
year in the US so that's a lot so is it
a delusion that people think this way do
we which we worry about it
psychologically you know I used to worry
about it because I get phone calls every
day from people who are having
difficulties with the aliens in their
personal lives and well in an institute
I'm sure people feel really distressed
about well you know an 8% of the public
according to one poll is actually being
abducted by them hauled out of their
bedrooms for experiments their mom all
right so you know I mean maybe it
improves their social life who's to say
I think it's no different than then then
the instinct towards religion and indeed
the instinct towards science it is it is
feeling ourselves to be a small part of
something much grander and in sending
out tendrils to find what those things
could be and we do that in our
storytelling cinematically yes and these
files and et men in black Independence
Day or the world's so you look at the
range of how aliens have been portrayed
yet if you ask anybody who has met them
they all kind of look the same they all
have this common report do we have an
image do we have an image of that see
they all look like that right so Seth
why do they all look like that how do
you get convergence on what an alien
looks like yeah in that way yeah well
there is something in biology called
indeed convergence you know I tell you
what the aliens really look like I don't
know if you can handle this but think of
what we're going to do and I scan I
can't handle the truth think what we're
going to do in this century which is
invent Thinking Machines the aliens have
probably already done that so the real
aliens probably look like machines okay
so now that we've all heard it out of
his mouth
we just need to everyone to look right
here
it's focus right there okay thank you
thank you for that what were we talking
about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh